اهلا وسهلا نادين اهلا سهام تحيه طيبه لكم
اول استاذه المشاهدين بالتاكيد اليوم قصه
دانه الهاجري احدى القصص الملهمه التي
حصلت هنا في السعوديه هذه الشابه التي لم
تتجاوز 22 من عمرها حققت نجاحا كبيرا جدا
في ابتكارها الذي حصل ايضا حصلت على براءه
اختراع من الهيئه السعوديه الملكيه
الفكريه لتعرف اكثر على المشروع ودانا
الهاجري ما هي التحديات التي واجهت الدانه
اهلا وسهلا بك دانه ابتداءا راحت فيك
بصباح العربيه اثنتان حدثيني ايش هو
مشروعك اليوم اللي انت ذكرته
مشروع الملكيه للحج والعمره
الدوله الاحتياجات الخاصه
اه تميز بانها
يخدم رمي الاحتيا رمل الجامعات
واتصال المركبه
المغنااه تتنقل هذه المركبه في حاله الى
اقرب جهات الاسعاف داخل الحرب
وتحديت الاعاقه وحققت هذا النجاح الكبير
حصلتي على براءه اختراع وهذا بالتاكيد
انجاز كبير يعني شو هو الشغب ايش الشيء
اللي ولد الشغب فيك اليوم انت دانه وخليك
تحققين هذا الانجاز ايضا انه لسه في بالك
طموحات اكبر
تم الحصول على هذا المشروع على شهاده
نموذج صناعيه
[موسيقى]
باذن الله نسعد في الحصول على شهاده
الاقتراع لكن حصل على شهاده نموذج
صناعي بخصوص
الشقق
الكبير
بعيدا عن ااا هذا تخصص الجامعه يعني من
طفولتك انت احب اني همم افتكر حلول بسيطه
عشان اعتمد على نفسي فيها همم من البيت
يعني حتى بابسط الاشياء كنت انا ووالدته
ولو العائله همم بس بابسط الامور اني مثلا
ابي افتح الباب وادخل واطلع همم معتمده
على نفسي فابسط شيء كنا نفكر
بالحبال نغبطها على كل الباب
ومن عشر سنين يعني يمكن 10 سنين الى امك
هذا عمر 22 سنه
كان عندي هذا الشرف اني اطلع من الاشياء
بسيطه بس اللي خلاص ما عاد كده اعتب عليه
احد اليوم الشباب والشابات في مختلف
مجالات الحياه بالتاكيد انه بالتاكيد انه
لك رساله لهم يعني ايش حابه توصل رساله
هذول الشباب
بالنسبه لطموحاتهم ايضا ان هم همم يتعدوا
ويتحدوا المصاعب ويقدروا ينجحوا
كل كل منه فيه ااا
او ان الحياه
مالها طعم اذا لم يعني
استغرقه الداخليه وكل من فيه قوه داخليه
لكن يحتاج انه يثق فيها يستغلها ما تؤثر
فيه الظروف ولا ولا احيانا ممكن المجتمع
فاا تجارب حياتك بناء على الشيء داخل فيه
اذا كنت مهزوز اذا كنت ضعيف او اذا كنت
ثابت فكل ما تحصل عليهم تجارب الحياه بناء
على الشيء اللي داخله
تستغل هذه الطاقه بدل ما تكون يعني
مستنزفه الى طاقه مغذيه لك وللحولك
اللي كانت عندك دانه في تحقيق نجاحك هذا
وبصيره حياتك كامله يعني احنا ما تكلم فقط
عن ابتكارك احنا اتكلم ايضا عن حياتك كلها
كيف انك تحديتي كيف انك قدرتي تصيرين بهذا
الشيء الكبير يعني حاكيني ابرز مكان القوه
اللي كانت معاكي
تخلق هذا
الحاجز انك انت معدي يعني
ما تحدد مثلا نظره الناس عنك او ما تقلق
لك نظره معينه دائره معينه طيب المواجهه
وبالتقبل انك انت تقبل جميع الجانب الكويس
الجانب الايجابي والجانب السلبي فيك
الصدق الذاتي مع نفسك
اني استحق الافضل دائما
وهذه النقاط اللي دائما ذكر فيها نفسي
جدا بوجودك اليوم معنا
اليكم نادين وسهام بالتاكيد هذا القصه قصه
كبيره تستحق الاشاده وانتقاله
تستحق كل التقدير والاحترام شكرا لكما
اسامه القاسم ودانه الهاجري شكرا لكم